I did you see,
you see how this works?
It's just while here are ways you can
be creative and here are a strata of
accomplishment within those ways.
And so then the question
is what does it look like?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Fair enough.
And,
and,
and this probably needs to
be updated to reflect that.
So,
so there's,
there's the distribution of scores.
Now that's dismal.
That's abysmal thing to look at.
You have to understand that,
why look at this zero,
right?
The median person has not done anything
creative ever in their life with
anything on any dementia,
right?
It's really important to know that.
And then you have these
horrible people out here,
right?
They do everything.
Price's law.
Here's price's law.
This is something to
hammer into your heart.
The square root of the number of people
in the domain do 50% of the work.
Okay?
So let's,
let's go through that.
You have 10 employees.
Three of them do.
Half the work makes sense.
That's reasonable.
You have a hundred employees,
10 of them do half the work.
That's problem.
So the other 90% are doing the other half.
Who cares about them?
You have 10,000 employees,
a hundred of them do half the work,
right?
So here's a,
here's a nasty little law.
As your company grows in,
competence grows exponentially
and competence grows linearly.
Got It.
Right?
Because with 10 it's three
who are doing half the work,
but at 10,000 it's a hundred
that are doing half the work.
So 9,900 of your employees are doing as
much as the best 100 you might not even
know who the best 100 are,
but probably they know and
maybe their peers know too.
And so one of the things that's really
interesting when big companies start to
shake,
which means maybe they've
had a bad quarter,
two bad quarters and the stock
price starts to tip down.
And the people,
the hot people who have options
are not very happy about that.
And maybe they start to announce layoffs.
All the a hundred people
who have opportunities leave
and they're the ones who
were doing half the work.
So boy that puts your company in a pretty
rough situation because now you've got
the 9,900 people left over who were only
doing half the work and the next time
you announced layoffs the next
most productive hundred leave.
And so then you're left with nobody
who's productive at a massive overhead
payroll price's law.
You can look that up.
Does sola price to solar price is
a guy who was looking at scientific
productivity and one of the things he
found was when he was looking at Phd
students is that the median number of
publications for a phd graduate when he
did his work,
which was in the early
sixties was one okay,
half as many had two half as many as
that had three half as many as that had
four.
It's a real step down and one of the
corollaries of that is that there's a
certain number of people who are hyper
productive and that's these people out
here.
And if you were graphing the,
let's say you graft,
how many people in a
population of 300 head,
$10,000 in a savings account,
it would look very much like this.
Some of them would have some of them.
Some of them would.
Most people would have
no savings whatsoever.
The median person would
have no savings whatsoever.
And then you go up here where the 1% is,
they have all the money.
But the thing you want to understand
about that 1% issue that you always hear
about is that it applies in every
single realm where there's difference in
creative production.
Every realm,
it doesn't matter.
Number of records produced,
number of records sold,
number of compositions written.
So here,
here's a,
here's an example.
Five composers produce the music that
occupies 50% of the classical rep
repertoire,
right?
Bach,
Beethoven,
Brahms,
Tchaikovsky,
Mozart.
That's right.
Those five.
Okay,
so here's something cool.
So you take all the music.
Those people wrote 5% of the music.
All those people wrote occupies 50% of
the music that of their writing that's
played.
So,
not only do almost all the
composers never get Alyson,
but even among the composers who do get,
listen,
almost none of their
music ever gets played.
So,
so then that's,
that's another example of
this price's law of scaling.
So when it applies to all sorts of things,
like number of hockey goals scored
is also distributed this way.
Number of basketball,
basketball basketball's
successfully put through the hoop,
follows the same distribution.
Uh,
size of cities follows
the same distribution.
It's a weird,
it's a weird law and you,
you can think about it in part,
why does this happen?
While imagine what happens
when you play monopoly.
What happens?
Everybody has the same amount
of money to begin with,
right?
So then you start playing,
it's basically a random game.
While some people start to win a bit
and some people start to lose a bit.
And then if you win,
the high probability that you'll
keep winning starts to increase.
And if you lose,
your vulnerability increases as you lose.
And then maybe you've got say
six people playing monopoly,
soon.
One person has zero.
What happens when they have zero?
They're out of the game.
So zero's a weird number
because when you hit zero,
you're out of the game.
So,
so then if you keep playing,
people start to stack up at zero,
right?
What happens at the end of the game?
One person has all the property and all
the money and everyone else has none,
right?
That that's what happens if you play
an iterated trading game to its final
conclusion.
And that's part of the law in a
sense that's underlying this kind of
distribution.
So it's a,
it's really,
it's,
it's not a consequence necessarily
of structural inequality.
It's built into the system
at a deeper level than that.
So,
you know,
people talk about all the time about how
unfair it is that 1% of the population
has the vast amount of the money and
1% of the 1% has most of that money.
And 1% of the 1% of the
1% has most of that money.
But it is a,
it's a,
it's an inevitable conclusion
of iterated trading games.
And we don't know how to fight.
We don't know how to take from the
people who have and move it to the bottom
without an instantly
moving back up to the top.
Different people maybe,
but still back up to the top
because even the 1% churns a lot.
Like I think you have a 10% chance,
if I remember correctly,
you have a 10% chance of being in the
top 1% for at least one year of your life
and a 40% chance of being in the top
10% for at least one year in your life.
That's in Canada and the U
S it's less so in Europe,
so there's a fair bit of
churning at the top end.
It's not the same people all
the time who have the money,
but it is a tiny fraction of the people
all the time who have all the money.
Yeah.
Do the people inside redistribute
to recreate the scene?
No.
Unusually.
I mean they do,
but it's attenuated.
Okay.
Because the people mean if you reshuffled
the entire company and put everywhere
somewhere else,
there's some probability that some of
those people would rise to the top that
weren't at the top before.
But in that company that that
isn't generally what happens.
People get stuck in their
niche and they don't move.
So yeah,
this is cool.
You wonder sometimes,
well,
how can companies die so quickly?
Well,
they go,
they go into a death spiral that's
almost impossible for them to get out of.
So,
and it happened.
It can happen extraordinarily quickly.
This is why,
you know,
the typical fortune 500
company only lasts 30 years.
That's it.
It's not that easy for these Bam Mos
to continue existence across time.
So,
and it's because it's really
easy for something to die.
It's very unlikely that it will be built.
It's very unlikely that it will
be successful and one successful.
It's very unlikely that it will continue
to duplicate it success because the
underlying landscape shifts on it
and it doesn't know where to go.
And that,
that's also partly because it's not that
easy to integrate creative people into
your company.
Right.
You certainly don't want them at the
bottom because they're supposed to be
people who are doing
what they're told to do.
So you filter out a lot of them at the
bottom and then you need them at the top.
But they've already been filtered out.
And also creative people are troublesome
to work with because they're always,
how do you evaluate a creative person?
You all,
you almost can't by definition because
they keep coming up with new things and
you don't have a good evaluative
strategy for a new thing.
It wouldn't be new if you had a
good evaluative strategy for it,
right?
It would have to be the member of a
class that you've already encountered
substantially.
So anyway,
so the take home lesson from this is zero,
right?
Right.
And then that's like,
that's like a graph of of money
and monetary distribution as well.
And the thing,
the problem with being at zero is
very difficult to get out of zero.
And this is also why people
get stuck in poverty.
You know,
you can't get a bank account if you're,
if you don't have any money,
right?
There's a bunch of things that start
to move against you when you're at zero
that you can't shake.
It's very difficult to get out of the.